dipping your toes in the sand in the ocean here
maybe a couple days shley back in a centering
pass towards Dylan drives it save jari and there's
no rebound penguin dumps it into the Winnipeg end
after it alexiah follow knocked off the puck Chad
ridle down low to ell jul Arvey risks one saved by
huk people that pay attention to the fashion
Chris leang is hair cut a little bit there's
gensel back in his pass bounces up in the air
towards the net safe huk rebound it wouldn't go
Crosby had a crack in tight shot prior to this
one but some action coming his way he's trying
to find that puck you can see Jake just kind of
swats at it heluk did the same thing with his
glove push it over to Marcus Pon launches it
forward a Char had it bounce off his leg he's
just taking the puck everywhere I think they
thought that was going to be offside he stayed
with it ER flings it on net and a pat save by hot
where Co prevented the NHL's participation in the
Olympics he was supposed to be the head coach
for Team USA yeah wildly successful coming in
as penguin's head coach and I mean his message
just hit home matang be Henry [Music] scores
off the turnover the Penguins pounce and
Chris latag comes out of the Buy on a by
one nothing [Music] Pittsburgh getting Pucks
in deep as pul Arby gets it in it's time to
go to work winning those one-on-one battles and
getting pressure and then it's a skill of Chris
leang he doesn't just stand there and hope he
attacks a quick pull to the backand honor huk
for the first strike of the game here everyone's
kind of watching Once L Tang grabbed that thing
and jumped into the zone here's Josh morresy Kyle
Connor slips in around Carlson flips it and a save
made by jari as Carlson will take it back around
for lar Ellen his wrist shot gloved by heluk and
no rebound there Top Line is looked really good
denel Crosby rust shley Wheels his way back in
poke check by jari as that developed quickly off
the stick the 55 and white get a look here shle
the big body power forward like move to the net
this gets a piece of it the little stick he just
kind of flashes it out right there Tristan jari
you're not in front jar stone walls the mov his
best sequence of the night Tristan jar up to
the task Baron net front and then from behind
the net to out front to domestico a bang bang
play as he's reaching for it with his stick as
well Carlson takes it two minutes gone on
the power play along the half walk PS it
to the net save hellu on the redirect by
Carter High a follow again to the pocket
he clears try to generate and create look at
this play Raquel just kind of held on to it
and trying to pull some of the here's Carlson
Raquel he can wire it over to Carlson back to
carel Carlson shot Lo Carter tucks it in
power play goal and the Penguins smash it
back in the Jet's [Music] [Applause] [Music]
face massive gold payback for this power play
what a great job by lar Zeller up in
that high slot this time Carter's at
the net front but it's that little tip
right there I don't know if Carlson was
looking for the high tip or just looking
to get a puck through Riley Smith off to
leang back to Smith Crosby for leang gel to
a tank Crosby will let it rip sulex in front
score Brian rust on the power play
again three nothing Pittsburgh
Crosby just kind of whiffed on that pack on that
onetime excuse me and everyone lost track of it
hellu going where was that he leaned into it
you can see how it threw it right off there and
it's a bodies around the net again Penguins just
swarm the puck swarm the net canel buns it the
two teams back to five on five but Pittsburgh
doing what they needed to do and back in they
come Russ triangles backhander save hak couldn't
get it around doing deelo good job holding his
ground as he gets it for Appleton up the wall
morresy across for Dello in the slot perfetti
holding shooting jar answers and keeps it out
then gets the toe on the rebound from Appleton
Power Play Goals a goal from Chris L tang and
hey you need some goal [Music] tending here is
Appleton centering pass Lowry j a great stop
his best of the night shell right now as a
puck just gets rimmed in and Spinner amama
no look P from Neer Off the Wall right here
finds Lowry look at jari just staying with him
all the he's just calm in there isn't he that
could have been a panic mode again he just
sat there calm let's it hit him Conor back
in backhander jari the save Crosby was there
too either way it stays out all of a sudden a
couple great chances from Winnipeg but nothing
getting by Tristan jar AS Conan comes back in
morresy for shley up over the net this game
start opening up here morresy downlo shley
scores and the Jets were pressing finally
they recover a loose puck right here just
a quick one battle morresy on a stick off a
stick shle back into this Jets lineup after
missing six games before the break it just
beats jar five hole is a quick react play boom
boom Pittsburgh has elected to use its coach's
challenge they're going to get a challenge in
an offside [Applause] here well that means
that our trusty video coaches CJ damante
and Madison nickel have pinged the Penguins on
the bench let's take a wide angle look at what
they are reviewing a little bit of chaos here
at this time too the pens were trying to make
a a change well that's that little delay by Kyle
Connor coming across the line of course you can't
see vard's feet down at the bottom here's a
better look this is a great look just that
little hitch delay as vard right in on the puck
and they got something as the crowd's getting a
look on the Jumbo Tron as well let's get the
verdict after video review it's been Thurman
that the play was offside therefore no go set
the clock to 13 25 here's Gres he'll risk one
that's knocked down by Mory lost the puck
to Malin he hunted it he dangles Malin wrap
around SA huk rebound Smith huk the save not
once but twice got you beat then he tries to
make that little pass back and the Gino with
the wrap round leading to a couple Point Blank
opportunities by back down into the Pittsburgh
end it's ' Conor for po Joseph pass picked off
by Dello Appleton around the wall Adam Lowry
throws it in front jar a spectacular stop on the
redirect yeah he's been really good and there's a
save look at all the traffic there you just have
to be so sharp and aware well these penguins they
get up for the best teams in the league and they
just took one of them down in a statement right
out of the bu a two-point Party on Fifth Avenue in
a league leading sixth shut out for Tristan jari
in a three- nothing victory over the Winnipeg Jets